now am I the only one who thinks it's
high time the government came clean over
its nuns on drugs look excuse the puns
this is a desperately serious and too
often even deadly problem that's
currently being handled well with all
the authority you expect when Chelsea
substitutes its goalkeeper the Home
Office has just licensed the nation's
first drug checking center in western
super Mare in Somerset users aged
eighteen and over can take their drugs
to the clinic to have them test it to
see if they're safe with no fear of
getting into trouble now this follows a
spike in drug-related deaths many in
seaside towns while everything should be
done to halt that what's next how about
a cab home and a bottle of scotch to
really make the night go with a sweet we
need some honesty here I'm all for the
medicinal use of cannabis and I see some
of the arguments for limited
decriminalization however with one arm
of the state offering to test substances
and the long arm of the law
simultaneously trying to lock users up
could we possibly just have a puff of
smoke of clarity over this this this is
typical of this country there's
wishy-washy attitude to drugs I mean the
charity that is spearheading this is
going to be running some of this is it's
a charity called addiction and and from
where I can see what what they're what
they're basically doing is they're
condoning the use of illegal drugs
although they say quite clearly they're
not but that's precisely what they're
doing and these clinics would have been
funded by the state this makes the state
a drug enabler this is not about trying
to get people off drugs
that's say to people bring your illegal
drugs in and and we'll test a little bit
and then you can off you go and you can
take your illegal drugs the whole point
of this is that we stop people taking
illegal drugs we hear no we you know no
we haven't because we keep hearing the
drug laws don't work ninety percent of
people in this country are not regular
drug users ten percent or so the ninety
percent have been prohibited by the laws
that we have okay it's authorized by the
Home Office is not actually funded by
the taxpayer no I realize that I know
but it is still the state backing and
dull drug use went under when there are
where there are laws to stop illegal
drug use and here we have the state
saying it's okay I mean and you had can
I just say this mantra fix this woman
rose get get in Suez who was the
director in charge of it she says our
job is to help people make informed
choices no the job should be to stop
people taking illegal drugs that might
kill them Greg if it helps people some
alive let me there's a beggin quote I
thought from this from this chapter
which is called action this is about and
this is from was getting who says this
is about saving lives we know people
take drugs we don't have to condone it
but nor should we judge people or bury
our heads in the sand it's our job to do
whatever we can to help people make
informed choices about the risks they're
taking it's home office license but in
addition to that we have a local
agreement with the police so that people
will not be stopped and searched on
their way in and out of buildings now
what is interesting is this is a trial
in one place I understand in western
super Mare although I do think it's been
done in several festivals trial I'm more
for doing trials like this to see if it
makes any difference what you don't want
is more more to get my point and I'll
bring you all understand we've got the
police trying to lock them up because we
know our drug policies all over the
place and has been for years I agree
that if there's contradiction but I
think as a society we need to figure out
what's what kind of society we want to
be so in an ideal world nobody would
take illegal drugs none of us would
drink to excess and you know it would
all be nice and happy and healthy
motorways we don't yeah yeah that's not
reality so therefore what you've got to
ask yourself is people will take illegal
they do they will and they will continue
to and I speak as someone whose formula
F has been was impacted by illegal drugs
in not a nice way and I also know more
than one person that has died as a
result of taking illegal drugs and I've
seen the devastation that that has
caused to families and to loved ones and
if there was a way that actually some of
those drugs could have been tested in
the beginning and actually said this has
been caught with something
this isn't a safe product for you to
take that may have saved life so we've
had almost 4,000 drug related deaths in
England and Wales in 2017 and for me
they are all needless deaths so whilst I
wish that people didn't take drugs I
think that actually is quite progressive
and a bold move actually to try and save
people that's good Trevor do you see the
point I'm making a mixed message tre
yeah this is going to make sure I never
get invited to certain North London
dinner party I'm with Nick on this for
two reasons first of all I agree with
you Greg we shouldn't judge people but
we can't judge their behavior and we can
say certain behaviors are not just to be
discouraged but they should be
prohibited and the second point I want
to make is I get Michelle's point about
you know the risk and so on but you know
if we were really serious about that
then okay if you're gonna let people to
test their drugs then they should pay
for it rather than everybody else if
they're going if there's a Belgian risky
behavior then they should pay for that
risk but the most important point is the
one that was made by the Commission
Metropolitan Police last year which is
that this is not a behavior in a bubble
what do we think all of those killings
that are going on in streets of
Birmingham and London are about they are
about drugs and unless we actually take
a zero-tolerance approach to this then
actually that's going to continue but
isn't that where it isn't that what
we've tried to do over many years was in
the Philippines and I want to say a
president do it so but I may well have
pronounced all that wrong and yeah yeah
he had absolutely enough of drugs and he
basically said I don't want drugs on my
streets and if you want to wander around
killing druggies and dealers you can't
and and there'll be no sanctions for it
that was
kissing's also says that people who have
had these their drugs tested then many
decide not to take them I don't buy that
it suggests that junkies have some
measure of control over what they're
doing and take someone who's addicted to
drugs going to a party and taking a line
of cocaine or an ecstasy tablet or you
know thing about like okay I want to
bring Greg in because I think you and I
possibly both not sure that we agree
with it I think we do supposedly have a
zero tolerance approach we're just not
affecting you I think we did for many
years and didn't work yeah I think we're
not sure what we're doing I think this I
would have in the old days of royal
commissions or something like it I'd set
up a commission to say look look at our
drugs policy let's look at it seriously
and let's looking find out if what we
ought to change whether we should no I'm
not saying I'm not saying at all they
might say that I'm saying let's look at
it because clearly what have we've got
at the moment isn't working well I quite
like this is I like the idea of small
files to see what impact they have
listen it might be if it makes no
difference whatsoever then you wouldn't
do it would you should we look at what
the Home Office is that and got to say
about this as well so they've they have
come out and said this government has no
plans to decriminalize drug possession
and it would be completely wrong to
suggest that the decision to issue a
license for approved research purposes
represents a change in this policy a
Home Office license was issued
so approved research could be undertaken
in addictions clinic in Somerset in
accordance with the terms of that
license all license applications are
considered individually on their merits
and I repeat my previous point which is
I think this is a bold move I think it's
a parade of festivals right there yeah
absolutely say it happened at festivals
last summer and thousands of people
actually went and got their drugs tested
and as I said there will be many people
that watch this program going on a
minute how is my government able to tell
me that I'm okay to drink alcohol but I
can't say it's fine for the people at
the festival and they get better they
get a better hitter or worse hit or
whatever it is
but think about what is happening in the
supply chain think about what happened
before those drugs have got to the
festival we're normalizing the taking of
a lead it already is normal that's for
many different people that's because we
have not acted we have not imposed our
drug laws on people who take drugs and
if we don't do that how can we expect
the problem to be any less
you mentioned the place you mentioned
before I think Shanghai has the same
kind of policy people are punished for
taking drugs now I'm not saying we want
to go down the road where people get
physically punished but there has to be
some sort of consequence for breaking
the law okay well this one can roll on
and on so let's move on